[Музика]
supra krasnogorovka Сайт служби
Раджив каттілін але торт Люсія Луїза
зісман а courante Аманат рожевий
todo seprieono Маврикій amico гортанний
Євгенія креативна в Урбані кокос
привіт хлопці прийшов час для уроку англійської
мови Наталі  розпочніть
сьогодні я хотів би вітати дуже
дорогий гість
привіт марічка привіт Наталія як справи
сьогодні я добре доглядаю за хребтом і як
ти я фантастичний
тому ми продовжуємо розмову про літературу
та читання я готовий до уроку так
точно
так  давайте почнемо, тож подивіться на
картинку, що ви думаєте, що це
таке, це книга, це книга так, це
не справжня книга, це не папір,
але це пам'ятник, чи
можете ви вгадати, де це мм-хм,
не знаю  але, можливо, там написано, що
насправді
це не так красиво
дуже добре, так що ти думаєш
про книги Січень любить читати
книги я люблю читати книги особливо я
люблю читати паперові книги добре, а
не читати електронні книги
я не відчуваю їх так, я абсолютно такий
же, я вважаю за краще працювати з книгою  щоб прийняти
це так, щоб ви брали книгу, ви
відчували запах книги, яку не можете відкрити, ви перегортаєте сторінку, це справді цікаво, коли у вас є електронна книга, ви відчуваєте
щось на зразок несправжнього відчуття, що ви
просто прокручуєте екран вниз  і
це все на вашому планшеті на вашому
телефоні, якщо це не ваше, так
точно, і я не відчуваю
присутності автора, коли беру паперову книгу,
я відчуваю, що, скажімо, сила
автора, і я читаю  рядки, тому ми
наче читаємо разом з електронними книгами. Я
не відчуваю цього відчуття, але
іноді це зручно, коли ти подорожуєш, тому
які типи книг ти читаєш, а не те,
що віддаєш перевагу я віддаю перевагу, як книги, добре,
як спати, як готувати  як схуднути,
але тепер я  більше в
детективи детективи це цікаво
ви згадали як підсунути книгу що
це означає як підсунути книгу я маю на увазі,
як людина, яка встає о 4:00 ранку я
читав про важливість сну
як заснути  рано і
прокинувшись, який найкращий спосіб
заснути, ага,
це як медитація, яка
вам потрібна, яка вимкніть свій мобільний
телефон раніше, правильно покладіть маску на
очі я буду використовувати цю техніку, яку я
ніколи не використовував  маска для очей, коли я лягаю
спати, я збираюся спробувати це, дуже
дякую за рекомендацію, тому давайте поговоримо
про типи літератури, що, на вашу
думку, існує три типи
літератури, які вони,
я допоможу вам переглянути  проза,
поезія, драма і драма, так, звичайно
, ми вже говорили про прозу
та різні типи книг, ви
пам'ятаєте, ми згадували
науково-фантастичну літературу, що ще ви можете
допомогти мені, марійка, будь ласка, люди, це дві
історії, добре і фантастика  n із серцем
історії кохання Римляни так добре
Дворяни романи класичні романи також
добре що як документ знати його
біографію над добре ми також
згадували фантастичні книги кримінальні трилери
книги жахів так багато різних книг
ми говорили про драму трохи так
драма  Це все про місце правильно, і
коли ми говоримо про англійську літературу, то,
звичайно, ми говоримо про Вільяма
Шекспіра правильно, давайте сьогодні поговоримо про
поезію, ви не проти, я не проти,
добре, тож давайте поговоримо про поезію, тому я
збираюся прочитати вірш  до вас спробуйте
знайти автора цього вірша, тому слухайте
уважно час дуже повільний для тих,
хто дуже швидко чекає, для тих, хто
боїться дуже довго для тих, хто
дуже коротко нарікає на тих, хто святкує, але
для тих, хто любить час вічний, хто
робить  Ви думаєте, що автор цього вірша
звучить як англійські дієслова,
це Вільям Шекспір так Вільям Ше
спір добре, і насправді ви можете здога
атися з телефонів, я думаю, прямо за шри
том книг, який горить  будьте
напруженими, так що ви думаєте про
час загалом, хм, я думаю, що це
те, що ми завжди сміялися, як
у підлітка Карен буде багато часу
для нових занять, добре,
а для мене час насправді щось на
кшталт дорогоцінної речі  це найцінніше
, і вам потрібно витрачати свій час по-
справжньому розумно, щоб не витрачати свій
час
NAFTA дитина шанс, що їхня мама
жаркий хор, який відновився зараз
добре, тому давайте подивимося на рядки
час дуже повільний для тих, хто  зачекайте, а
що це означає дуже повільно для тих,
хто чекає, як ви розумієте це
іноді, коли ви очікуєте,
що станеться якась дуже важлива річ, здається,
що століття, коли ви чекаєте п'ять хвилин,
ви хочете, щоб це сталося дуже скоро о,
наприклад  ви чекаєте, поки ваш
друг прийде, а він або вона запізнюється, тому
ви чекаєте і запитуєте, чи пам'ятаєте ви
дуже відомий мультфільм,
наприклад, Шрек, коли вони подорожували
,
ми там  тут все ж так,
справді
ні, так це наче у вас є 10
секунд, а для вас це як одна
хвилина, тому ми можемо сказати, що
час дуже повільний для тих, хто чекає, тому що
ми не любимо дуже швидко чекати для
тих, хто наляканий  що це означає
для тебе, перше, що мені спадає на
думку, це чекати прийому до стоматолога,
а коли ти приходиш до
лікарні і думаєш о, можливо, у тебе є
півгодини, щоб відпочити, і вони сказали, що я
прийду так, насправді  чи добре
боятися, що ви вважаєте природним, це
природно так, але іноді нам потрібно
дивитися обличчям у обличчя, ви згодні так іноді
нам потрібно переживати цей страх дуже
довго, щоб вони були,
це те, що нове жінки скаржаться,
це висловлює жаль  м'яко клітинка
гавотує тиск, який вони перезавантажують для
тих, хто знову дуже довго скаржиться, це
щось подібне до правильного очікування, тож якщо
ми подивимося на цю фразу, чувак, ти керував ним
Знову так довго, давайте
перейдемо до наступної фрази, дуже короткої для
тих, хто добре святкує, якщо вам подобається
робити те, що ви хочете робити
довше, і якщо вам нудно, це було щось
схоже на попереднє твердження
ммм, час був довгим і коли  вам
щось подобається, часу було мало
так,
тому ми зазвичай говоримо нижче X Pollock simcha
так, тому ми хотіли б, і час минув,
наприклад, ви чекаєте вечірки,
яку готуєте до вечірки, і
як ви проводите  п'ять годин на ньому, але для
вас це як п'ять хвилин, це дуже
швидко, тому що ми насолоджуємось з любов'ю і
святкуємо, давайте з останнім, але
для тих, хто любить час вічний,
термінал - це те, що
ніколи не вмирає так, що триває вічно, тому я думаю
весь вірш про час і сміх
, так що час дорогоцінний, а любов
дорогоцінна
добре, ти віриш у внутрішнє чи добре,
сподіваюся, мені не доведеться перевіряти це на власному
досвіді, тому я бачу, що вірю в любов,
яка триває в реальному часі добре добре
молодець с  o давайте продовжимо сьогодні, я
навчу вас новому віршу, добре, подивіться на
ці малюнки, як ви думаєте, що це
вірш про шоколад про
шоколад чи любите ви шоколад я зробив
смачно смачно, тому перш за все слухайте мої рядки
мені і спробуй згадати
картинки добре просто послухай і
запам'ятай картинки коробка, повна шоколаду
хіп-хіп-ура коробка, повна шоколаду
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат від коробки до мого
часу
шоколад смачно смачно так  це дуже
простий вірш, і в мене є питання,
перш ніж ми вивчимо вірш, але ichika,
як ти думаєш, чому нам потрібно вчити вірші,
тому що дуже добре тренувати свою
пам'ять
, наприклад, якщо ти запитаєш когось
на землі, що ти знаєш  про
Лондон, що кажуть Лондон —
столиця Великобританії, тому що ми
вивчили цю расу напам’ять і використовуємо
їх, тому вірші дуже гарні, ви їх вивчаєте,
і у вас є ці знання
в руках, тому ви дуже швидко відтворюєте їх
давайте спробуємо ще раз з віршем, але зараз
я буду говорити, я збираюся
сказати вам вірш і покажу їхні жести, добре,
тому я і ви слухайте мене, я показую вам, а
ви повторюйте за мною, але кожен з них може зробити
з  я добре, ти не говориш ти просто
подивися на мене і повтори дії добре
готовий,
так що ти повторюй дії за мною книги
повні шоколаду
hip-hip-hooray книги повні шоколаду
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат з коробки  моєму
Tommy chocolates
смачно смачно ладно так давайте спробуємо ще раз
я скажу вірш ти повторюєш тільки
дії ти нічого не кажеш
марічка ти готова так я скажу
твій шоу книжки повні шоколаду
хіп ура
ура  коробка повна шоколаду це моя ціна
сьогодні
трикутник прямокутник коло і квадрат
від коробки до мого животика шоколад смачно
смачно фантастично зараз я
покажу дії, які ти намагаєшся продекламувати вірш,
щоб ти сказав вірш марічка ти
мені допоможеш добре і  Студенти, за якими можна стежити за
Маріською, так готові
коробка, повна шоколаду, ура, ура, гірка,
гірка, хіп, ура,
коробка, повна шоколаду, це моя ціна
сьогодні  до цього трохи пізніше, і я
хотів би привітати мого дуже дорогого
автора Герберта Портера за цей вірш, я
все ще пам’ятаю його, дуже дякую, тому
давайте перейдемо далі, подивимося на
ці малюнки, насправді це вірші,
і ми називаємо їх віршами форми, тому  як ви
бачите першу картинку, що це і
восьминіг, восьминіг, так, і у нас є
вірш про восьминога, послухайте мене, Олівер,
восьминіг під морем,
дуже повільно плаває, шукає свій чай,
дає трохи зеленого,
привіт, заходять риби  добре, тут є
помилка риби, ми не говоримо риби,
ми кажемо риба, а множина правильно, але
іноді у віршах можна опустити бабусю,
добре, щоб побачити, чому його називають
віршем про форму через форму нашого
восьминіг пише, що у нас є рядки, написані як
його ноги, давайте подивимося на цей,
це інакше, це мій кіт ганяється
за хвостом, він його зловить чи зазнає
невдачі, це знову римований вірш,
і рядки роблять обличчя кота добре
його капелюх, тому ми говоримо про
слова, що римуються, і це легко, наприклад, побачити
дерево праворуч, тому давайте потренуємося, тож
давайте поглянемо на картинку, ви можете побачити
шість слів, я даю вам 15 секунд, спробуйте
записати слова, які римуються з
цими шрифтами  наприклад, дивіться дерево вільним і
так протягом
15 секунд запишіть слова
п'ять чотири три два одна зупинка, будь ласка, добре
багата машина, ви готові
майже добре, тому давайте спробуємо сказати,
що це буде як пінг-понг, я говорю
це слово вам і ви  відповідай мені добре,
так що кулінарна книга добре,
співай, співай добре, добре, дім, дім,
добре, три три ночі, добре,
побачиш мене добре,
це дуже приємно, давайте подивимося на ці
слова саме так, кухар,
ти сказав, книга, що ще ми можемо отримати
з кулінарною книгою  поговорити Лука Лука Лук  e
правильно, дуже легко, а
як щодо раковини, я сказав, думати, а ти також
сказав, що раковина також правильно, що ще, тоді
сцена так, насправді, це може бути тонко, правильно
, тому що ми зазвичай не
вимовляємо букву G, тому сцена правильна річ
добре, а як щодо si si, то є  також
номер три три так бачимо три безкоштовних
дійсно безкоштовних мишачий будиночок і сніг падає на
гілки роки добре, а як щодо ночі я
сказав супутник, це всередині, а що
в кімнаті, що у нас на верхньому
світлі, у нас також ніч з
нічною нічкою добре  то чому ми використовуємо
слова, що римуються, нам легше
створити вірш правильно, тож давайте
на пісню це пісня Лемке,
щоб вона думала, що все відразу, вона
називається, давайте подивимося на рядки
хитрий, як лисиця  сильний як віл
правильно, тому цю пісню дуже легко
слідувати через римовані слова, адже
вони для нас, щоб запам'ятати так швидко,
як заєць, хоробрий, як ведмідь, як ведмідь,
вільний, як птах, акуратний, як слово, добре
Чи можете ви прочитати далі, будь ласка, так тихо, як
я  ну великий як будинок все, що я хочу
бути всім, що я хочу бути, о, все, що я хочу бути, це
все так, дуже легкий вірш,
тож тепер завдання, вибачте, я забув
згадати, щоб запитати вас, чи знаєте ви всі
слова, які я  не впевнений у лукавому, тому,
люди, як ви можете описати цих тварин,
люди, так, тому ми кажемо хитрий, як лисиця,
сильний як віл, правильно, це добре, а як
щодо слова акуратний
о, привіт, назвіть мою роботу або що піклується, добре, і
якщо ми подивимося  у виразі all
I wanna be so Warner, що означає
хочу, так, це це просто
скорочена форма для розмовної мови,
коли ми пишемо граматичний тест, це
недобре писати, але коли ми співаємо
пісню або декламуємо  вірш, це добре, я сказав
вам, що іноді ми можемо пропустити граматику чи
пунктуацію, коли пишемо вірш чи
пісню, тож давайте спробуємо створити свій власний вірш,
тож це завдання для вас,
не поспішайте або слідкуйте за нами, і ми
збираємося продекламувати  вірш для вас, тож давайте
розглянемо рядки, чи хочете ви
створити власні слова, або ми дотримуємося  ці
слова я можу стежити за вашими добре, давайте,
так що ніч, можливо, це була ніч або це
ніч до міста, я можу не поспішати так
так,
не поспішайте, подумайте про вірш,
тому, хлопці, я готовий перевірити давайте почнемо
з марійки спавну  Я не міг спати
вночі, тому я увімкнув світло в кімнаті. Я
схопив, щоб почитати книгу, щоб дізнатися більше
про фантастику. Я вражений бурою
оплесків шлюбу, який був дуже гарним,
тому в якийсь момент згадайте, що я показав вам
свої фотографії  вірш коробка, повна
шоколаду, чому я показав тобі
картинки і чому вони використовували дії,
як ти думаєш, можливо, є якийсь
зв'язок між мозком, га, те, що ми
робимо, і тим, що ми говоримо, це якось
взаємопов'язано, тому що я пам'ятаю, що
діти в  у дитячому садку всі вони вивчають
англійські пісні, показуючи на собі
ми всі різні, і у нас
різні канали пам'яті та
стилі навчання є візуальні учні, які
бачать картинки і запам'ятовують дуже швидко
, тому ми використовуємо картинки, які
є  для тих, хто слухає і
запам’ятовує дуже швидко,
для них дуже важливо почути
інформацію, а є кінестетики,
які люблять рухатися, тому ми
використовували дії, тому всі ці три речі
згадуються у вірші, перш за все,
ви бачите зображення, а потім ви  послухайте
вірш, а потім виконайте дії, щоб це було
зручно для всіх, тому я пропоную
вам намалювати малюнок до свого вірша,
наприклад, я не міг спати вночі,
що ви можете намалювати, я не міг спати,
щоб ви запам'ятали моє  вірш
коробка, повна шоколаду, щоб було
зображення коробки і шоколаду, це
для вас, вам не потрібно бути художником,
так добре, це я, ммм,
покажи нам, будь ласка, так, добре, великі очі і
світло горять і означають, що
не спиш  Гаразд, наступний рядок дуже
простий я і книга про кулінарію,
яка насправді дуже реальна в наш час, ми
повинні готувати весь час для нашої сім'ї,
я люблю готувати, це мій другий пацієнт,
тому, коли ви не пам'ятаєте їхні рядки,
ви можете просто подивитися  на малюнку, і
це буде як сплеск у вашій
голові, о, я це правильно пам'ятаю, тому це
як символи, ми називаємо їх символами або
коротким планом, і ви можете використовувати малюнки, якщо
ви візуально навчаєтесь, зараз буде легко
давайте переглянемо вірш, який ми
сьогодні вивчили про шоколад, так що це буду
я перший, а потім твоя черга коробка
повна шоколаду
hip-hip-hooray коробка повна шоколаду
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат від коробки до моєї
животик шоколад смачно смачно мариська
можеш спробувати будь-ласка коробка цукерок
хіп-хіп-ура коробка повна цукерок
це моя ціна сьогодні трикутник прямокутник
коло і квадрат від коробки до мого
животика шоколадна смакота гарна фантастика
я сподіваюся, що сьогодні сьогодні  він також
продекламує цей вірш вашим дітям, і
вони також навчатимуться у вас, але
насправді я пам'ятаю картинки у своїй
свідомості, і саме так я міг би його продекламувати
правильно, тому це означає, що якщо ви пам'ятаєте,
що малюнок маленький, це означає, що
наприклад,
я кінестетик, напевно, мені потрібно
рухатися, і я пам'ятаю дії швидше,
ніж картинки, для мене дії
важливіші.
картинка більше, це
означає, що твій візуальний візуал я, якщо ти
пам'ятаєш дії, це кінестетичний
фу-у-у, навіть візуальна Алісія для тебе, а
якщо ти пам'ятаєш сам вірш у
вухах, тобі не потрібно уявляти якісь
картинки, це означає, що ти  Ви
слухаєте слухач
OSHA's premium oslo добре, тож перед тим, як
ми закінчимо урок, давайте
знову поборемося з настільним понгом за римування слів будь-які
слова, наприклад, я кажу стіл стіл
стіл добре, якщо я кажу стілець
там добре, тепер давайте спробуємо навпаки
ви дайте мені слова я збираюся римувати це
добре, щоб стрибати,
гм, добре, мабуть, як це
вечеря переможець вечеря переможець фантастично
давайте спробуємо ранок ранок
позіхання позіхання фантастично давайте спробуємо
стіна стіна висока стіна маленька це легко
прямо тут ar  Слова, які дуже
важко римувати, наприклад, я сказав
вам таблиця, це як просте слово, але
в той же час у нас є закінчення Abel
Abel, тому це все як Abel кабель, який
можна правильно, також це закінчення Abel,
але якщо ви думаєте про  такі слова, як
ммм,
навіть наприклад маркер маркер Паркер
мм-хм, і вам потрібно правильно подумати, тому якщо
ви не пам'ятаєте або не можете
придумати жодного слова, просто погуглите римовані
слова, і Інтернет допоможе
вам, хлопці  вашим домашнім завданням
буде написати свій власний вірш, якщо ви ще не
закінчили його під час уроку та
надішліть його нам, будь ласка, використовуйте електронну пошту, і
я перевірю ваші бали та
найкращі моменти, які я збираюся продекламувати  тут
онлайн, тож запишіть мою електронну адресу
Наталія дот школа онлайн на gmail.com
я чекаю на ваші вірші
дуже дякую Марія дуже
урок вам сподобалось це було дуже приємно
дякую добре так що було
найцікавіше з  на
уроці найцікавішим було кататися на власному
по  їх і щоб запам'ятати твоє, чи можу я попросити
тебе продекламувати це ще раз, будь ласка,
твій або мій, твій так, я не міг спати
вночі, тому я ввімкнув світло в кімнаті, я
схопив, щоб почитати книгу, щоб дізнатися більше,
як готувати фантастично Сподіваюся, що ти
продовжиш свій вірш і також надішлеш
його мені, якщо ти дуже дякую, я
буду добре, дякую, до побачення, мій
нобута Кітс Кальвадос енергійний кунжут
Ешворт тому, що наша відкрита духовка х залишає
Gwadar TV icky Buddha видалити чи вони
якісь розбрат суперклас  квітка ті
речі досягли найбільше деякі з нас
у тилу вона була жінка
[Музика]
ти